les propos d'Emmanuel Macron sont
retours de Pékin n'en finissent pas de
provoquer des remous en estimant que
l'Europe ne devait pas se laisser
entraîner vous l'avez suivi dans des
crises qui ne sont pas les siennes et
qu'elles ne devait pas non plus suivre
avec Le Mans les positions américaines
une prise de position française pas
vraiment du goût des médias américains
le New York Times estime qu'Emmanuel
Macron s'appelait efforts américains
pour contenir l'influence du régime
chinois dans la région je laisse son
président Macron le soin de répondre aux
commentaires nous sommes très à l'aise
et nous avons confiance en cette
alliance forte et en cette grande amitié
qui existe entre nos deux pays nous
travaillons ensemble sur le continent et
dans le monde entier avec la France si
nous restons au spectateur de ce qui se
passe entre la Chine et Taïwan alors
continuellement la communauté
internationale et la France sera seront
spectateurs de tous les désordres du
monde ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes
les alliés des États-Unis que nous
devons être contre la Chine et nous
n'avons pas être pris à partie dans
cette rivalité qui existe entre les
États-Unis et la Chine
nous voulons bâtir l'indépendance
européenne l'intégrité de Taïwan ne peut
pas être remise en cause par la Chine
et c'est la position de la
l'Union européenne mais aussi de la
communauté internationale et
heureusement que nous n'avons pas tenu
ce raisonnement là pour l'Ukraine avec
la Russie à peine rentrée de Chine
Emmanuel Macron s'extrait de la crise
des retraites et repart à nouveau à
l'étranger en l'occurrence au Pays-Bas
[Applaudissements]
un président français obligé de
suspendre son discours avec une
interpellation où est la démocratie
française la Convention sur le climat
n'est pas respectée vous avez des
millions de manifestants dans les rues
chaque fois que le Président de la
République va dans un pays il braque la
moitié de la terre on a la moitié de
l'Afrique qui veut plus nous parler
parce qu'il a braqué les dirigeants
africains aujourd'hui il braque un
certain nombre de leaders européens qui
ne comprennent pas la sortie d'Emmanuel
Macron et avoir dégainé un 49 froid dans
ses circonstances là pour forcer la main
en réalité de du peuple français a été
très mal vécu ça restera je pense une
cicatrice profonde au même titre
peut-être en termes d'intensité que le
référendum de 2005 et bien Adrien
catenas se député du Nord va être
réintégré au sein du groupe la France
insoumise nupestre décision qui est
tombée vers 13h15 j'ai pas vous dire ce
que j'ai voté voyez-vous
c'est une affaire extrêmement complexe
compliqué qui a blessé l'ensemble du
groupe l'ensemble des membres du groupe
et que s'il avait été membre du groupe
socialiste il en aurait été exclu c'est
d'abord ça notre position vous n'avez
pas honte musqué
ça me fait un peu rire si je crois le
propre des sectes de demander aux autres
d'être vertueux et de se comporter au
sein de même un peu comme ils veulent je
crois qu'on aura compris le vrai visage
de la France insoumise là il va revenir
mais
aucun retour ne sera légitime aux yeux
de la population aux yeux de plein de
gens tant qu'il n'y aura pas eu de
sanctions légitimées par le groupe
assouplir souhaiter de réintégrer ton
actes nous on dit bon on veut plus qu'il
soit dans les instances de la nupcesse
c'est-à-dire dans la structure de
coordination et on veut plus forcément
que ce soit un interlocuteur tout ça ça
c'est un groupe que nous cogérons et
donc là nous avons notre mot à dire avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je n'ai plus de
rapport c'est le choix qu'il a fait je
regrette moi je l'ai appelé je lui
envoyais des courriers il souhaite pas
me parler mais il vous répond pas non
voici la paire de basket qui valait 2
millions de dollars la maison de vente
aux enchères sauce bise va juger ce soir
une paire de Nike alors pas n'importe
laquelle les Air Jordan porté par
Michael Jordan lors des finales de la
NBA en 1998 un an et demi après le décès
de Bernard Tapie son épouse Dominique
est ruiné l'homme d'affaires a laissé
une dette de 660 millions d'euros dans
l'affaire du Crédit Lyonnais
elle en a déjà remboursé près de 150
millions grâce à la vente d'un hôtel
particulier parisien et d'une villa à
Saint-Tropez des enchères ont déjà
atteint 1,8 millions de dollars mais
elle pourrait aller jusqu'à 4 millions
fait la dette se creuse un peu plus à
cause des taux d'intérêt 90 000 euros en
plus chaque jour Dominique Tapie raconte
vivre aujourd'hui avec le strict minimum
environ 800 euros par mois